deux événements à fêter ce soir deuxième
événements futurs déjà le retour de
Kelly Vedovelli
ah oui une petite opération et c'est
bien tout va bien je peux regarder ou
pas franchement ça c'est rien c'est
limite je voulais que je vous dise
limite je vous préfère comme ça
c'est vraiment vous êtes pas mal donc
franchement non vous aviez une vous avez
mais moi je sais que moi aussi j'en ai
ah bon moi aussi j'ai un expert alors
moi il m'a arrivé la même chose que
Kelly moi j'ai aussi j'ai un kyste ici
une boule un jour je suis au ski et je
vais moi ce que je suis
elle connaît l'histoire je suis au ski
je rentre dans l'ascenseur je me vois
dans le miroir je vais pour skier et moi
quand je me prends pour un beau gosse tu
vois j'y vais je kiffe
là j'arrive frère et je vois dans
l'ascenseur je vois que j'ai une boule
ici sur la tête de ma mère t'as pas dit
je suis rentré dans l'hôtel je me suis
allongé j'ai appelé toute ma famille
tous mes amis j'ai appris Kenny
j'appelle tout le monde c'est vrai j'ai
appelé tout le monde toute ma famille
toutes les habitudes j'ai dit ça y est
c'est fini
c'est terminé c'est fini l'histoire
pas vrai je suis resté allongé comme ça
au revoir à tout le monde un médecin
peut-être non d'accord je suis resté
deux jours en croyant que j'allais
mourir tout le monde allait au ski tout
le monde qui fait jeter comme ça au bout
d'un moment j'ai appelé mon père
il m'a dit envoie-moi une photo voilà et
les médecins quand tu lui envoies une
photo il s'appelle
c'est comme les garagistes quand tu
arrives tu vois tu montes ta voiture
Bernard
à mon avis là il y a le train arrière
qui a été touché c'est sûr c'est la
maladie et donc voilà donc là il fait
FIA pas bon pas bon et là il m'envoie
chez un gars le gars me fait un déco
tout ça il me dit c'est bon c'est rien
de l'eau tout ça je peux rester comme ça
je dis limite moi j'aime bien non mais
c'est vrai au moins j'ai vraiment j'ai
la boule ici
un truc elle avait la même boule ok
ouais et elle et elle a fait enlever et
donc voilà franchement moi j'aurais
jamais le courage faut l'enlever parce
que on sait pas ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur et on m'a dit que c'était
placé derrière la jugulaire et que ça
grossissait ça pouvait avoir des
complications je les fais enlever c'est
un plus gros que prévu de le faire moi
je l'ai pas fait à l'ouest mais vous
êtes là c'est l'essentiel
[Applaudissements]
moi je l'aurais pas fait
c'est quoi un jeu parce que franchement
moi pour l'instant je reste comme ça
j'aurai rien à de boule en plus
elle a jamais dérangé personne
franchement hein voilà donc il
franchement bravo pour votre courage non
franchement je vous jure que c'est vrai
parce que moi je te jure que moi je
l'aurais pas fait du tout